hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ihr wisst bescheid ich bin
ziemlich blöd habe ich allerdings noch
nicht immer ich habe nämlich weil meine
mutter gefragt ob sie mir mal einen
ordner geben kann mit allen meinen
bisherigen zeugnissen das sind alle aus
meiner grundschule und da hinten sitzt
übrigens wieder dass haushalte lappi
gefräst oder geschönt werden beitrag
meine mama hat mir auf jeden fall sonst
hätten ordner gegeben mit mindestens
50.000 verschiedenen zertifikaten
urkunden irgendwelchen raumfahrt
bescheinigungen da ich war schon auf
mono auf jeden fall waren da wirklich so
was von vielen urkunden zeugnisse et
cetera denn das nicht mehr einfach
gedacht hab ich zeige euch im rockigen
video erst mal meine zeugnisse aus
meiner grundschulzeit ich weiß nicht wie
es bei euch ist wenn eventuell in
österreich wohnen oder in der schweiz
oder eventuell auf einer nordfriesischen
insel es ist glaube ich auch noch mal
ein bisschen anders oder ob es nicht
allgemein jetzt von zeit zu zeit auch in
den bundesländern geändert hat wenn mir
was auf jeden fall so dass ich vier
jahre lang in der grundschule war vom
jahr 2002 bis 2006 also von meinem
sechsten bis zehnten lebensjahr und
hinsichtlich der zeugnisse was bei uns
so dass man in den ersten beiden jahren
nur so texte bekommen hat was man für
ein mensch ist und dass man alles kann
und was man nicht kann und im dritten
und vierten schuljahr bekam man den
richtigen noten also nicht so punkte wie
wir das irgendwie nach auf der
weiterführenden schule dann bekommen wir
sondern wirklich so befriedigend sehr
gut um genügend hat je irgendein kind
ein ungenügend in der grundschule
bekommen auf jeden fall würde ich jetzt
sagen wir fangen an mit meinem zeugnis
aus der klasse 1a
das war einfach 2002 sind zehn jahre her
da zeugt von unterteilt in drei
kategorien einmal arbeits und
sozialverhalten da ging es darum wie man
mit mitschülern klarkommen und das
schulleben an sich angeht dann leeren
entwicklung und leistungsstand in den
techno wird gesagt hey wie liest man wie
schreibt man wie rechnet man nun gab es
doch ein feld die das schiff bemerkungen
da wurde beispielsweise bei schülern
hingeschrieben ein bisschen auffälliger
waren unterricht sei halt mal dein maul
jetzt hier fangen mal an mit dem arbeits
und sozialverhalten lieber luca du hast
nicht schnell an das schulleben gewinnt
das ist schon irre überhaupt deinen
mitschülern und lehrern begegnest du mit
zurückhaltung aber freuen sich und
ausgeglichen streitigkeiten gehst du
lieber aus dem weg und so kommst du gut
mit allen aus das panel jan als werden
sich alle über streit und ich empfinde
es wäre zeit für alle themen des
unterrichts interesse arbeit ist
aufmerksam mit und beteiligt sich freue
mich mit gut durchdachten beiträgen
dabei erkennst du zusammenhänge und
kannst dich rasch auf neue sachverhalte
einstellen
wahnsinnig war krasser schüler im
schriftlichen bereich erledigst du alle
anfallenden aufgaben selbstständig in
einem angemessenen arbeitstempo und sehr
ordentlich zusätzliche hilfen benötigst
du aus dass selten
ok also mein arbeits und sozialverhalten
war zurückhaltend aber gut von mir nun
allerdings in meinen schulfächern und
zwar steht hier du kämpfst alle
erarbeiteten buchstaben und die
dazugehörigen laut und achtet beim
vorlesungen geübter texte bereits auf
die sinnvolle betonung alter ich kannte
in der ersten klasse schon alle
buchstaben und die lautet alle anderen
hersteller bald keiner kommt dann läuft
die osram auch ungeübte geschichten
kannst du selbstständig erlesen
inhaltlich erfassen und mit deinen
worten zusammenfassen beziehung werde
wieder geben du verfügst über einen
umfangreichen wortschatz erzählt
anschaulich und verwendest treffender
ausdrücken aber du hast doch aufmerksam
zu wenn andere reden und bist in der
lage auf deren beiträge einzugehen alter
die logen mit jakob lenz hier steht
jetzt auch das nicht rechnen kann dass
sich zügig finden der mathematik und
auch der zehner übergang mir keine
probleme bereitet also von neuen +3 und
dann dass man weiterhin das schiff zwölf
bemerkungen hatte ich keine und hier
steht dann noch das luca ab dem ersten
acht 2003 am unterricht der klasse 2a
teilnimmt dann hier noch halt
unterschriften et cetera das habe ich
halt alles zensiert und damit würde ich
sagen machen wir auch direkt weiter mit
meinem zeugnis aus der klasse 2
hey leute 2003 2004 das ist zu krank
lang her arbeits und sozialverhalten
lieber luca auch im zweiten schuljahr
hast du dich stets freundlich und
aufgeschlossen deinen mitschülern
gegenüber verhalten und konntest du ein
freundeskreis erweitern
die nur freunde ist eine zuverlässige
ruhige art wirkte ausgleichen in der
klasse und hass so zu einem angenehmen
klassenklima beigetragen im unterricht
beteiligt du dich heute ich mit
konstruktiven beiträgen bist aber auch
in der lage auf die äußerungen anderer
einzugehen denn die schriftlichen
arbeiten erledigte sehr selbstständig
mit großer sorgfalt um zügig also
eigentlich der text aus der ersten tasse
ein bisschen umgeschrieben kommen wir
nun zur lernentwicklung mit dem
leistungsstand in den fächern und zwar
steht hier im lesen hast du weiter gute
fortschritte gemeldet dass japan sind
ich konnte so gut lesen liest texte
flüssig und überschauen vor äußerst sich
zu inhaltlichen fragen und gibt es die
bedeutung des gelesenen folgerichtig
wieder deine sprachliche
ausdrucksfähigkeit des umfangreichen
differenziert so dass du mündlich und
schriftlich anschaulich und
zusammenhängen zu erzielen vermag ich
war ja wie albert einstein wollen ich
glaube aber nicht mehr gut in der schule
du schreibst in druck- und
schreibschrift schön und gleichmäßig und
für seine hefte sehr ordentlich oh mein
gott stimmt da musste man ja noch hefte
führen was gab es für euch eigentlich
für typische grundschule sachen also so
etwas wie die hefte führung oder die
streitschlichter ag cor et cetera oder
auch milch holen bei uns gab es jeden
tag drei leute hat er der schoko und
vanille milch aus dem lehrerzimmer holen
dürften für das herze klasse das gerne
in die kommentare weil mich interessiert
es mal mega wie es beispielsweise auch
bei euch in österreich oder bayern
im burghof ist aber guten wenig freunde
wir machen weiter mit mathematik und
zwar steht hier in mathematik beherrscht
üppigen grundrechenarten im zahlenraum
bis 100 und setzt einen sitzen bei der
erarbeitung neuer aufgabenstellungen oft
gezielt einen kannst dich schnell auf
veränderte aufgaben form umstellung des
in der lage sachaufgaben zu durchschauen
und ohne hilfe zu lösen ich hab sache
aufgaben wie die pest gehasst sie
geübten einmal ein freien beherrscht nun
ebenfalls sehr sicher bei unseren
kleinen kopfrechnen test hast du so gut
wie keinen fehler gemacht
wahnsinn wieder keine bemerkungen und
ich werde in klasse 3 a versetzt somit
der klasse 3a meine lieben freunde
kommen wir auch direkt schon zu den
ersten noten die vergeben wurden
ich war ja übel hut religion habe ich
eine zwei deutsche unterteil den
sprachgebrauch lesen und rechtschreibung
dass ich ihn sprachgebrauch 12 in lesen
und rechtschreibung einer einst sogar in
englisch hatte ich eine zwei mathematik
zwei sachunterricht 3 das hat er noch
mehr sachunterrichts hätte ich gar nicht
mehr weiß dass es ja wohl auch nicht so
wichtig gefühlen kunst habe ich eine
zwei musik mit 2 und sport sport mit
zwei btf außerdem steht hier noch du
hast an der arbeitsgemeinschaft
streitschlichter teilgenommen
das war so witzig will hat mit den
tausend oder so ein gelbe käppis auf und
gelbes t shirt allein nicht so richtig
peinlich aber werden uns wie die
coolsten gefühlen weil wir streite
aufgeklärt haben er muss alle gefühlt
wie officer film aber werden nie was zu
tun also das waren auf jeden fall meinen
noten im abschlusszeugnis der klasse 3 a
das ist ein schnitt von 1,9 also
eigentlich ganz ruhig und dann gab es
dazu aber trotzdem noch einen text also
in den klassen 1 und 2 gab es nur diese
texte in klasse 3 gab es einen text und
die noten und in klasse 4 gab es dann
wieder nur die noten sitzen fließender
übergang im arbeits- und sozialverhalten
von luca in der klasse 3a lieber lukas
sich aufgeschlossen für alle neueren
sehr eifrig am unterrichtsgeschehen
beteiligt seine beiträge zeigen dass du
bedanken weiterführen und klar
verständlich darlegen kann es für die
erledigung einer schriftlichen aufgaben
warst du oft weniger zeit als geplant
auch weil du immer sofort
konzentriert angefangen hast die haben
mich geliebt alter trotz des schnellen
arbeitstempo hast du sachgerecht und
sorgfältig gearbeitet das verhältnis zu
den mitgliedern ist nach wie vor
harmonisch alle arbeiten mit ihr
zusammen beziehungsweise lassen sich von
dir helfen alte was geht ab mit kleinen
texten meiner lernentwicklung und meinen
leistungsstand in den fächern wurden
unterteilt und die verschiedenen fächer
im fach deutsch konntest du deine
lesefertigkeit noch weiter
vervollkommnen du bist nun auch fähig
auch unbekannte texte anschaulich
vorzutragen und den inhalt des gelesenen
in logische abfolge wiederzugeben du
verfügst in der rechtschreibung bereits
über ein solides regel ist und so
unterlaufen die bei diktaten kaum fehler
aber auch in der gestaltung einer
schriftlichen arbeiten bist du schon
recht sicher deine eigenen geschichten
sind anschaulich erzählt und
abwechslungsreich formuliert hatte tier
das auf das ihren arbeiten teilweise
einfach eine geschichte ausdenken musste
das ist so witzig die wird einfach
gesagt ging die eine geschichte aus und
du musst mindestens zwei seiten
vollschreiben kommen nun allerdings zum
fach mathe und zwar steht hier im
mathematik unterricht beherrscht aber
alle behandelten rechen arten und löst
die gestellten aufgaben zügig um fast
immer richtig hat fehler gemacht oder du
erkennst rechnen vorteilen durchaus
sache aufgaben und finde es auch beim
neuen aufgabenstellungen die richtigen
lösungswege häufig allein krass aber
jetzt kommt sachunterricht war meine
schlechteste note auf dem zeugen das ist
dem sachunterricht folgte weiterhin
aufgeschlossen und interessiert einfache
zusammenhänge konntest du häufig
erkennen aber nicht immer auf andere
probleme vertragen
der englischunterricht macht ihr spaß
meldest dich gerne bringt sein wissen
ein arbeitsanweisungen verstehst du
meist nicht sofort und für sie aus kurze
geschichten und reimer er fast nur in
der regel schnell und kannst sie wieder
geben
oh mein gott hier steht musik und so
bist du bereichert interessiert den
musikunterricht wings gerne lieder und
hast gut bei der erarbeitung der
blechblasinstrumente mitgearbeitet ich
singe gern wieder als erworben die das
denn her genommen das war ein
abschlusszeugnis der klasse 3a ich hatte
wie auch bei den anderen zeugen dessen
keine bemerkungen und wurde in die
weiterführende klassen
versetzt das waren meine noten in der
klasse 4a die waren wirklich heftig gut
religion 1 englisch 1 und sachunterricht
1 und in allen anderen fächern hatte ich
eine zwei leute das sind schnitt von 1,7
ich habe aber beim abschluss zeugnis der
klasse 4a über zwei bemerkungen und zwar
just in diesem jahr an der
radfahrausbildung teilgenommen und die
prüfung mit erfolg bestanden wo ich weiß
leider hat sich eine verfahren alter an
jeder kreuzung stand ein elternteil und
hat gesagt wo man ein paar muss und sie
hat sich verfahren auch im
sportunterricht hast du die bedingungen
für das sportabzeichen in bronze erfüllt
wahnsinn sportabzeichen ehrlich gesagt
habe ich nie verstanden warum man diese
kaka gemacht hat warum haben sportlehrer
nicht einfach gesagt hey nicht durch den
wald die jungs spielen fußball und die
mädchen können tanzen auf jeden fall war
das mein grundschul abschluss zeugnis
von meiner gemeinschaftsgrundschule in
meiner heimatstadt damals nämlich hatte
einen schnitt von 1,7 wurde
dementsprechend auf das gymnasium
versetzt heißt es versetzt keine ahnung
auf jeden fall bin ich aufs gymnasium
gekommen auch vom gymnasium hatte ich
dann klasse 5 bis klasse 12 das ist ein
sieben luca auf jeden fall weit dann
sieben jahre lang auf dem gymnasium und
hab dann dort auch mein abi gemacht
falls dir dort meine zeugnisse sehen
wollte und wollte dass ich einen zweiten
teil machen wie ich meine zeugnisse
zeige da kamen keine bemerkungen mehr
also keine texte aber dann kann ich mal
meine noten zeigen und zeigen wie es von
1,6 luca runtergegangen ist auf 2,8 luca
als youtube angefangen hat heute der
boxdorfer das gerne mal einen daumen
hoch bei diesem video das schaffen wir
40.000
das wäre auf jeden fall kraft und war
nach heidenarbeit diese ganzen zeugnis
herauszusuchen und so zensieren aber
sonst meine damen und herren will ich
nicht auch sehr sehr freuen wenn ihr
meinen kanal abonnieren würde also unter
dem video einfach auch abonieren klicken
dann seid ihr offizieller teil der nuku
und wenn ihr dann abonniert habt könnt
ihr auch gerne auch die glocke klicken
dann bekommt er immer benachrichtigungen
wenn ich ein neues video hochgeladen
habe und seit die ersten und könnt ihr
etwas kommentieren jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]